23 year old was driving in the southwest
valley early tuesday morning when police
say former raider henry ruggs slammed
into her car killing her and her dog
sasha loftis spoke with tina's childhood
friend tonight and she joins us near
rainbow and spring valley parkway with
more sasha
denise and brian tina's best friend says
she was with her just moments before
this horrific crash happened you can see
this memorial is growing in her honor
with balloons candles photos of tina and
her dog maxine now her friend says they
were just out for a walk with that dog
and she never imagined things would have
ended like this
a candle lit for a young life stolen
boyana felipovich shares what she loved
most about her best friend tina tintour
she's brilliant she's smart she's
intelligent she's very charismatic the
23 year old and her dog were killed in
this fiery crash at rainbow and spring
valley parkway tuesday morning and
boyana was with her just moments before
it happened your mom was calling me
crying like hey can you check if it's
the car that's her car she wasn't coming
home it's an outcome she never could
have imagined
and police are now shedding light on
what led up to the collision involving
former raider henry ruggs this is a case
of the state of nevada versus henry
james runs the third investigators say
ruggs was going 156
miles per hour before he slammed into
tina's suv
and cited his blood alcohol level as .16
twice the legal limit records obtained
by our eight news now i-team describe
ruggs as uncooperative and incoherent at
the hospital yelling slurring his speech
and trying to remove an iv from his arm
now as boyana tries to move forward she
will always remember tina's light she's
always one of the good for everybody and
she knows the bond they shared will last
forever i love you very much i'm sorry
that i didn't get to say goodbye
boyana says the tina emigrated here from
serbia when she was around five years
old that's about when the two became
friends she tells us that tina loved
animals she went to durango high school
and she planned to go into the computer
science programming field
reporting live tonight sasha
live
now